Britain's Prime Minister says another
terror attack could happen at any time
in the United Kingdom police in
Manchester England made three more
arrests this morning in connection with
Monday night's bombing 22 people some of
them children died in the explosion
we're learning the names of more of
those victims this morning local
officials now say 119 people were hurt
64 are still in the hospital a British
tabloid this morning claims to show the
suicide bomber celeb BB police are
examining his ties to Libya where his
family is from the British government
has raised its terror alert to the
highest level of critical meaning
another attack may be imminent police
say that the man who set off this bomb
after an ariana grande concert may have
friends who are planning another attack
CBS Evening News anchor Scott Pelley is
in Manchester right now and joins us now
with the latest got good morning good
morning Gail the heightened state of
alert has taken effect across Great
Britain today thousands of soldiers are
being sent to stand guard at local areas
all around the country to free up police
officers for counterterrorism duty in
London Buckingham Palace canceled this
morning's traditional changing of the
guard so the police could be deployed
elsewhere and Britain's Parliament is
now closed to all visitors until the
security level is lowered Mark Phillips
is here with the latest on the
investigation Mark Scott however tragic
this bombing appeared at the beginning
at least according to the police it was
simple the bomber they first said acted
alone now they're not so sure the police
raids in the area around the home of the
suspect have led to increasing
suspicions that the Manchester bomber
may not have been a lone wolf sallman
IBD whose picture now appears in British
newspapers had been considered a minor
figure on the fringes of Islamic
militant movements but not a dangerous
one he was born and bred in Manchester
to a family that had left Libya in the
90s but he had traveled back there
lately and security officials suspect
may well have traveled to Syria and
have been more directly connected to the
so-called Islamic state than they
thought the attack on the concert crowd
of mostly young people appears to have
come just a few weeks after a body
returned from his last trip and security
forces now suspect a connection the area
of Manchester PD comes from and where
the police have been operating has been
known as a recruiting ground for Isis
with a dozen or so of its young people
going off to fight in Syria the police
raids here have led to the conclusion
announced by Prime Minister Theresa May
to raise the security level this means
that armed police officers responsible
for duties such as guarding key sites
will be replaced by members of the Armed
Forces which will allow the police to
significantly increase the number of
armed officers on patrol in key
locations there wasn't much in the way
of security to be seen as Mancunian
'he's got back to work but the sense of
living in a secure city perhaps always
something of a delusion is gone
raising the threat level to critical
implies by the old definitions of these
things that the authorities fear that an
attack may be imminent in this case what
they're saying is they can't be sure an
attack is not going to happen
in other words Scot this bombing has
demonstrated what the authorities don't
know rather than what they do Mark
Phillips thanks very much mark